some understeer Firdaus clean shoes
connected to my aunt assistant in
Motherhouse the specimen right the track
volume is V emergency Koenig Anatolian
it is realistic average McVicker
[Music]
my name is dick Andrea on the second
20mp issue in part is here in the
paradise back to that first archetypical
team to hold cities around bath for
fenced-in yard on the side of our eye
and have the color island about also
happy ownership in the a daily
occurrence near and dear partner in the
gear position Daryl arrived this Indian
language yet confusion bottom as a
service Napoleon business owners now via
Yahoo less difficult houses contingent
Vasco designers confirm I'll be no sound
on a thermal it is traveled through some
of the containers they assigned
something house it's attacking foreign
tectonic I'm technique solution
understand India I am feeling turn on
the fire engine output and take it back
to her
dhanyavad endeavour home delighting via
bad unless mr. Zetas I'm a legacy
the best I'm very excited angry both
missing Lisa pollination disability
mental health difficulties the committee
size of this opportunity as of essence
economy as the thinking the content
which part of the body man's are
specialists in our potential and
something Jenny the unusual very clean
and keen a desk I would get dressed up
once yet the child take away all the bad
luck together maybe hopefully government
with Harbor she touched up with your
buckle unity one of these new buyers and
I wish you good luck
I'm Angie Taylor and the Bunnymen have
something to say to reclaim obviously
the over the house and first to take on
value and dry them off
yeah well a collaborative market and
they actually saw the Bhargava confucian
there are t-shirts tomatoes and rosewood
and then they just kept abreast of omni
say much one by one for fifty two one
[Music]
they cut yeah did you do this escape
yeah you thought you'd feel comfortable
you set down and uncomfortable you're
walking and uncomfortable yourself you
never really that comfortable but as
much to help us come to learn and
recommend it will be pulled and the
people also feel a but also just make
sure I'm okay because I can't you don't
evacuation chair head what on the horse
often very those much as I can enter
streets walking over them come over
grams of ASCII and I'm going to use and
run on the ground
but don't take a support or mother
w'iskey stop all of it also appreciated
and then I had the high street going to
all the pubs restaurants for
lisa.gillespie I must wander 810 male
overall Alice cake
inclu say specifically you get very
excited on the deal for a man your
normal s body my mistake
they're all billions like all come out a
very pelvic of this an athlete reduction
not many people conceded in the body man
there's only a Sarah I look all the
happier body - open faces clinic you're
fired up so could it everybody 904 sighs
this is a very big honor he informs of
Queensberry for my life next to the body
man servos seven eight year old planter
class on the software the person is over
just carries on a fantastic session
that's only open because I had such a
unique especially in the level one
factor that should be another topic
everyone and all the Abunimah
beautiful baby
[Music]
early on a writer for one of the
traditional whisky magazine wrote that
our product tasted like sheep it's like
she pissed I mean that was so ridiculous
and so absurd people said how would
somebody know what she fess tastes like
and if in fact that's what he's drinking
he should be disqualified from ever
judging whiskey again there's a whiskey
shortage in the world right now not
everybody realizes it but prices are
going up some bottles are disappearing
from the shelves because people can't
keep up with demand
typically you make a distilled spirit
you put it in a barrel and you wait for
each or 10 or 12 years and I'm not that
patient a person generally the stuff
that we make only takes about 24 hours
we're not a craft distiller we're not a
micro distiller we are a technology
company that works in the whiskey space
80% of the flavor in a whiskey comes
from the wood there are some amazing
woods out there that we couldn't build
barrels from because they would leak
like a sieve we take the clear spirit
and along with the wood we put them in
pressure capable stainless steel tanks
squeezing the wood like a sponge moving
the alcohol in and out of the floor
structure of the wood the industry
thinks that's harrassing what we do is
sacrilege they think it's awful just
like people thought the internal
combustion engine was awful and the only
way to get from point A to point B
faster was to breathe faster horses well
that has obviously changed and we're
changing the very nature of the whiskey
industry might even call it whiskey why
wouldn't you call it where is their
clean up technically it meets all the
requirements of a whiskey or a bourbon
or whatever we happen to be making if we
call it something else
retailers wouldn't know what to do with
it why should it matter how we make it
what should matter is the taste I've
always been sort of a troublemaker I've
always been a rule-breaker like wow we
did something and nobody ever tried this
before that's
cool our founding fathers were blue
towns so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed especially since water wasn't
always clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington wrapped up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just fifty four delegates stone me and
John Adams went on a seven week binge
drinking six hours a night with younger
congressmen keep drinking so Franklin
took a stab at his peers and published
the terms he overheard at local pubs in
the drinkers dictionary here's what they
said I've got calls in my head oh go eat
a pudding bag Thomas you're one to talk
Washington you're as dizzy as a goose
I'm jambul my goodness Hamilton you've
got a brass eye today well the king was
his cousin clearly gentlemen you're all
wasted
[Music]
when you find a tree that has an apple
and just discovering new varieties it's
just I mean I live for that I'm Annie
Brennan my wife and I we surround our
town and we Gorge for a wild apples and
we make it into a series of sliders
based on where the apples are located
you still with the grammars each other
yeah yeah Gramercy Tavern which I've
only not what I know it's famous
especially their wine menu is what
famous having cider made from wild
charged fruits is really unusual
something that can only be done in very
small amounts what comes out of the
bottle is really special
[Music]
we go out into the woods we go to places
where apples are not at all influenced
by human cultivation we're searching the
woods and sometimes it's difficult to
find the trees and if the light doesn't
hit the silver and the trunk just right
you may not even know it's an apple tree
you're in luck when you find not just
one or two but a whole forest of trees
which sometimes does exist what I love
is discovering varieties that are just
so peculiar you would never find them in
a grocery store the other day we found
an apple that has red flash so you bite
into it and it just looks like a
pomegranate they're telling us process
takes about four hours to grind and
press enough juice to fill a barrel
because those barrels is there's
hibernating nine months after you've
collected the apples that's when it's
ready
you
[Music]